reino unido- termina el día con una
pregunta crucial quien reemplazará a
boris johnson la renuncia de johnson
deja abierta la contienda para encontrar
un nuevo líder para el partido
conservador podría demorarse en un
principio hasta otoño johnson aseguró
que continuará como primer ministro
interino hasta encontrar un nuevo líder
de los tories estos son algunos de los
principales aspirantes crisis unac el ex
ministro de hacienda fue una de las
dimisiones de la última crisis en la
política británica su nombre suena desde
hace tiempo como reemplazo de johnson
como líder tory list tras la ministra de
relaciones exteriores se espera que
presenten su candidatura pertenece al
ala dura de los conservadores y cuenta
con el apoyo de las bases de su partido
shaheed javi el ex ministro de salud ya
hizo una apuesta por el liderazgo en
2019 participó en la ola de renuncias
con un fuerte discurso contra el primer
ministro
nadine saharaui y el actual ministro de
hacienda pidió a johnson su renuncia y
algunos medios locales están impulsando
su candidatura
dominik graf el vice primer ministro
podría ocupar el cargo de primer
ministro interino ya lo desempeño en
2020 cuando johnson se cuenta 19 otros
candidatos que suenan a ocupar el cargo
son el parlamentario y jeremy hunt la
abogada general del estado suela pre
berman quien ya lanzó su candidatura
públicamente penny more town es
secretaria del estado ferviente crítica
de johnson por su escándalo del partido
o bng balance ministro de defensa y uno
de los miembros del partido más leales
al saliente primer ministro